le temps
avec tout cas
où es tu
depuis que je suis toute petite je pense
qu'à danser
[Musique]
si on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir à vannes
qui deviendra la meilleure de toutes les
danseuses et moi le plus grand menteur
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre et alors
j'avais tout ce travail est tout sauf
vous
chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera
illuminé qui déversait sa technique est
parfaite
demain matin entraînement à 5,5 heures
du mans quand
via l'ex alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle
si tu auras fait dans le club quelque
chose qu'elle n'aura jamais
la passion
un garçon il est beau gosse
dis que je vais devenir une étoile c'est
ce que j'ai toujours dit mais il est
trop tard
il faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves
ce qu'avait tout auteur
je trouve que que tu es génial tu fais
quoi là euh je m'étire tu vois on
regarde ça y est demain matin
entraînement à 5 heures du matin tu dois
apprendre à maîtriser tentative alors je
n'aurais jamais ce rôle si tu leur as tu
as dans le coeur quelque chose qu'il
n'aura jamais jacuzzi
le projet est arrivé chez nous en 2010
quand eric summer et eric varin sont
venus nous présenter et on a tout de
suite eu un coup de foudre pour le sujet
fun and shipping
depuis que je suis tout petit je pense
qu'à danser quand j'ai vu rosita maury
sur scène j'ai su que je voulais comme
elle et que je ferai tout pour réaliser
mon rêve
on a très vite senti le potentiel une
promesse de récits qui contenait plein
de valeurs qu'on avait envie de
transmettre en particulier dans le cadre
d'un film d'animation
cette histoire on voulait vraiment la
raconter de façon universelle donc
s'approcher des standards de l'animation
américaine assez rapidement on s'est dit
qu'en fait le meilleur moyen de
maîtriser à la fois la fabrication d'un
point de vue artistique et d'un point de
vue budgétaire c'était de créer
nous-mêmes de toutes pièces un studio
d'animation et de monter une nouvelle
équipe
m
faire passer
théodore tiennent bien acteurs de
l'animation et a participé à différents
films tels que mullan le roi lion les
cinq légendes comme fu panda
sa grande expérience son talent vont lui
permettre de traduire toutes les
émotions et toutes les valeurs portées
par le fils de notre
ce qui nous a bouleversés dans ce pitch
c'est le potentiel d'attaché à cette
histoire un message très inspirant pour
les enfants le thème de ne jamais
renoncer à ses rêves
ouais
depuis que je suis toute petite je pense
qu'à nancy
[Musique]
si on s'en fout ensemble ce soir by quoi
il deviendra la meilleure de toutes les
danseuses et moi le plus grand inventeur
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent
vous avez tous travailler tu chauffes
bout
chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera
éliminé clinique versait sa technique
est parfaite
demain matin entraînement à ce que 5
heures du mans
[Musique]
via les tour alors je leur ai jamais ce
rôle si tu auras fait dans le coeur
quelque chose qu'elle n'aura jamais
la passion
à
garçons et les beaux golfs
il dit que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit mais lui
il est trop intense
il faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves
dans ses caves est tout autre
je trouve que que tu es génial tu fais
quoi là euh je m'étire tu vois regarde
ça y est oui depuis que je suis toute
petite je pense qu'à danser
[Musique]
si on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir by one
qui deviendra la meilleure de toutes les
danseuses et moi le plus grand inventeur
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent
vous avez tous travaillé tueur chauve où
chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera
éliminé non clinique versait sa
technique est parfaite
demain matin entraînement à 5 5 heures
du matin
yannick alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle
si tu auras fait dans le coeur quelque
chose qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
garçons et les beaux gosses
et dis que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que je t'ai toujours dit mais
lui il est trop intense
qu'il faut jamais renoncer à ses ray ban
dans ses avis tout autre
je trouve que tu t'es génial tu fais
quoi là euh je m'étire tu vois regarde
ça y est on regarde c'est une école de
danse à paris la route à trouver
moi j'ai été super excitée parce que
j'adore le personnage de félicie c'est
une petite fille qui a un tempérament
extraordinaire parce qu'elle renonce
devant rien depuis que je suis tout
petit je pense qu'à danser et surtout
dès qu'ils y arrivent des coups durs
elle se relève instantanément pour moi
c'est un modèle d'humanité et un modèle
de persévérance moi je rêvais d'être
comédienne depuis tout petit et je suis
contente de pouvoir faire ce que j'ai
rêvé de faire il faut jamais renoncer à
céret on n'est que des enfants connais
personne n'a fait que c'était de la
folie du couvent est danseuse
j'ai été très contente de le faire et
c'est vrai qu'en arrivant j'ai un petit
peu déchanté ce que je suis mais c'est
super dur fait aller au début on voit ce
qu'il faut faire mais ils n'y arrivent
pas forcément et puis tout d'un coup il
ya un moment où ça y est le personnage
est dans le corps la voix il trouvait
les elle est bien placée du toit on va
nous entendre un son ne sort de ta
bouche
[Musique]
incroyable d'arriver à trouver son corps
en gardant une vraie sincérité parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'émotions dans le
dessin animé il ya des enjeux qui sont
qui sont forts et ça c'est une histoire
profonde
on se retrouve demain même endroit mêmes
portent les dangers je serai
oh
avec tout mon coeur
[Musique]
proulx et choisit vite
depuis toute petite pause cadence et si
on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir tu
deviendras la meilleure de toutes les
danseuses et moi je deviendrai le plus
grands inventeurs
tu as un plan un plan infaillible by
royal
venu à paris princesse c'est quand la
dernière fois que tu te laver les dents
[Musique]
ça y est je suis danseuse à l'opéra
enfin je suis élève pour l'instant
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent sauf vous
dès demain nous commencerons les
auditions chaque jour l'une d'entre vous
sera éliminé qu'une adversaire
camille cette technique est parfaite en
du pli et le mot perdre ne fait pas
partie de son vocabulaire
demain matin entraînement à 5 heures 5
heures du matin je suis l'étoile alors
que toi tu ne brisera jamais
tu dois apprendre à maîtriser tant
vestiges
[Musique]
alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle si tu
leur as tu as dans le coeur quelque
chose qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
un garçon il est beau gosse
il dit que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que je t'ai toujours vive
danse avec ton coeur
tu fais de la danse ou du kung fu
tellement drôle